and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a are tonight's review
Despicable Me do oh my god this is a
greatest movie I've ever seen in my life
ok back ok I give up
I think into canto del amico boilers
here's this guy who looks like the
penguin except this is an evil villain
who wants to take over the world and he
seems to be constantly interrupting the
story about these minions come on guys
stop hogging the spotlight we all know
it's the minions movie you may have an
interesting design but these are Simpson
penises people love Simpson penises be
sure there's a story about these three
girls and how the penguin guy is
supposed to look after them who cares
just give me the censors penis eggs but
then the movie is like we'll give you
your Simpson penises free but in
exchange there will be very little story
and very little focus on our main
characters but that's what your
advertising was doing to begin with and
that's why we're going to beat the Lone
Ranger but they do give us a few more
characters outside of the sense of
penises like Kristen Wiig is Lucy who's
just normal from the Looney Tunes show I
said now she has human boobies I had
human boobies once I would never find a
way to smoke estrogen again so human
boobies kidnaps the penguin and takes
into an underground lair where they look
after supervillains and professor
melting double chin is like we're the
people who stopped supervillains if
someone tries to steal the moon we try
to stop it then why did you try to stop
it what I did it that was back when we
wanted storylines to carry through now
are about funny scenes that don't really
connect that well oh you mean like this
scene with the Simpson penises you
better but it's funny cuz I don't know
what they're saying
kind of like politics don't I tell the
penguin that he has to go after this
other supervillain who's living in the
world cause small oh my god this mall is
awesome
everything looks unbelievable if there's
a coffee shop the store is shaped like a
giant coffee if there's a shoe store the
store is shaped like a giant shoe if
there's a proctologist I don't think
he'd be in the mall he being something
else too so they're trying to track down
this villain in the mall who apparently
has this stuff that turns people into
evil grimaces I wasn't evil grimace once
it's what they do to you when you ask
how chicken McNuggets are me
and the penguin thinks it might be this
guy named el macho who is the most macho
person who ever lived
even more macho than Chuck Norris mr. T
Stevens ago rock Peter Dinklage's sense
of self-worth Peter Dinklage a sense of
self-worth if he has a son Nate that
puyol and he says macho ass a little
Peter Dinklage broke out and one of the
girls is in love with him they're not
the smallest cute one no not the one
everybody forgets no not love the
minions and drag fun taking one that's
it and the penguin is like no I will not
have you dating sexy little boy's father
what did you I'm realizing how creepy
that came out but nevertheless you can't
see him well it looks like this is a
problem that's gonna create some real
conflict yes I suppose we both have to
learn something Alisa plane really fat
plot device comes to split us off and we
get back to Moore Simpson penises oh
look he's with another girl but but it
turns out the person they thought was a
bad guy then they prove what's in the
bad guy it turns out what's the bad guy
what a twist
ish and the macho comes across human
boobies and is like I must capture you
and keep you as bait to lure the penguin
but wait did we totally establish before
that I know all these karate moves and
I'm perfectly capable of taking care of
my site the climax we need something
fast and we didn't really have time to
develop anything outside of the Simpson
penises I can't even try using my
lipstick taser no my karate moves no can
someone at least knock me out from
behind or something no I'm just going to
grab your arm very tightly trailing with
my only weakness oh good good didn't
even think so the penguin goes to save
human beliefs defeats the evil beg a and
the two of them get married that's the
girls finally have a mother to look
after him you are the greatest mother in
the world oh if it's so kind even though
we only have one scene together we
barely interacted and when we did it
kind of looked like I was having a
a moment for you okay we already had one
whiskey kick joke in this review let's
not push it
hey so despicable me 2 was lots of fun
and really funny so I'll admit it could
have used a needlessly long violent
cowboy scenario with a man who somehow
is doing both white face and red face at
the same time what do you mean I'm the
only one who thinks that but a will who
cares I got my sensor penises yeah
actually I think these minions are
starting to wear off not like in the
movie just saying guys do one more movie
in that stop PCs jittery boom sing get
your judge I got out of a guy out we
never get on judge I'll use a doubt
great the Simpson penises I hear the new
design makes it look like yellow vicodin
you